the south east and the south of thing
will get more a lot more money than what
we get and we probably turn over a lot
more money for the government at all is
a lot of big engineering companies and
what I bein but doesn't seem fair nobody
knows the situation better than the
people that live here and the people
that work here so i don't i don't see
why london should control what happens
in manchester yeah more power to each
thinking if manchester compete for
itself that good thing and as long as ya
then they can arise decision I think
potentially a good idea as long as
they're also providing funding for all
this and the night betting loads retro
administration without that all the
funds to pay for it and the resources to
pay for it in principle and yeah I think
so because it's a less London centric
policy and it would mean a mayor here so
like a Manchester Boris which would you
like us enough and there might be good i
don't know about a Boris slow in
particular you could get someone bad